[Music]
we're going to go to victoria british
columbia with josh hey josh how are you
i'm doing good how are you doing today
good what's going on
can you hear me all right yeah you sound
great what's up awesome uh so i'm 21 and
i make just over 100 000 right now and
sort of on track to
be doubling that within a few years and
at my age i find that like
my my girlfriend's brothers friends and
such they're not necessarily at the same
place as me uh with with their finances
and
whenever we go out and do things i find
that sometimes i get anxious about maybe
where they're at financially or
is what i'm asking them to go do things
is that going to inflate their lifestyle
because like i know what it took for me
to get where i am and i don't
necessarily want to
be the influence that's making them
spend more money than they can and for
me i'm more than happy to pay for them
and
be able to take them on trips when i
want to go do things with them because
for me spending time with them is more
important than than thinking about the
thousand dollars or a couple hundred
dollars that it takes to take them out
and do that
i just don't want i want to make sure
that i'm not um
i don't want to be putting them down
anyway by making them feel like they
don't have the money to do that and i
also don't want
um i don't necessarily want to
inflate their lifestyle to a point where
then they're
if for some reason i don't pay for a
trip then they're going into debt
because they have never learned to save
for that yeah i wanted to have any tips
on how to sort of navigate that yeah
well first of all i want to commend you
on a couple things number one you're
making a killer income at a very young
age so way to go
second of all i love just how
considerate you are josh the fact that
you're asking this question shows what
just a good guy you are you're looking
out for your friends from a financial
standpoint but also from just their
feelings and how they feel about things
which is really really cool um that's
that's really really impressive a couple
things i would say and george you hop in
here but here's just off the top of my
head
um number one um i would definitely make
you paying for them
the exception not the rule because if it
becomes a pattern then you start to feel
pressure too and then there's this weird
dynamic where they expect it then that's
gonna put a real weird dynamic on your
friendship that you don't want so i
would say default to everybody pays for
their own thing
and um and when you ask them to do
something you can say up front like hey
guys i was thinking about do this what
do y'all think and if they say like i
don't have the money right now whatever
cool you can back off
or
if they do then they're grown-ups and
you can't be responsible for their
financial choices because you invited
them to a party and they made a bad
decision to attend you're not managing
their bank accounts so let's start with
a clear boundary there
but when you do pay for something i
would throw in one piece of advice here
when you do pay for something i would
try to pay for it as
discreetly as possible and again this is
the exception not the rule so let's say
for example um you guys are all out to
dinner and you just want to pay for the
dinner and drinks and stuff you might
you know go to the restroom grab the
server and say hey here's my card let me
cover this and when the server comes
back they're like what happened i just
wanted to get it this was fun and don't
make a thing of it if you make a thing
of it then it becomes this thing like
you're the guy that pays for the things
and then it tilts the room of like
you're the guy that like is paying for
everything and yeah extra bottles of
wine on on josh it doesn't have to be
like that like i would just i would
handle it super discreetly when you do
it which is a really cool move that you
are a generous guy and willing to do
that um but i think that's just going to
protect the friendship so that they
don't feel
in debt to you if it's the exception not
the rule and when you do it you do it
discreetly that's that's what came to
mind for me george what would you add no
that's spot on and on top of that i
would just say having that community
that line of communication where you're
saying hey what what is the budget what
can you guys afford i'm happy to
to match that so that we can make this
happen i think that's awesome but
there's also a lot of things you can do
that don't cost a lot of money so don't
always make it a thing where hey we're
taking big lavish trips big lavish
dinners make it just a chill thing where
we all split some pizzas and that they
pay their fair share uh because i think
that gives them dignity i think that's
what you're worried about you don't want
to take away their dignity and be showy
and they all of a sudden go wow this guy
is he's really something and he wants us
to know it and i think that's where
christy's heart is as far as the kind of
the discreetly doing this stuff and my
brother's that way he's super generous
and he's always the guy that sneaks over
and gets the server pays for it and
we're all like whoa dude what what the
heck he's like i just you know just
makes city yeah it makes it easy don't
just put the bill yeah he's just a super
sweet generous guy and i feel like
that's your heart josh what i don't want
it to come across as is pride yeah
whereas just look at me and i feel your
heart behind that you don't want it to
be that way so find things that are
cheap that don't cost a lot of money and
do that stuff too yeah i think if you
have a good mix of that if you have a
good mix of um cheap stuff that
everybody contributes to um maybe some
some nicer things that everybody
contributes to and then every now and
then you get the tab on something or or
even if let's say it was a concert or
something and you knew everybody was
free everybody wanted to go and you're
like hey guys i was able to get tickets
let's go and then it's not this weird
thing of like them watching you pay for
it and it's a big show i think just the
more under the radar that you can keep
that um that transaction that will
maintain some of their dignity but you
still get to do what you want to do
which is be generous and you still get
to be with your friends and share with
them and they get to participate in some
of that stuff but man josh you're an
awesome guy you're a really awesome guy
thanks for calling thanks for thinking
of your friends and thinking of how that
would affect them and um and yeah i
think that if you do it that way it will
come across in the right way but just
know that when if if you got in the
habit of just paying for things all the
time it does tilt the room and and
that's not what you want so i love
george's advice of just do some stuff
that they can afford hey what's the
budget you know when when me and all my
friends we're grown women but when we
get together to go on a girls trip we'll
say like where do we want to stay what's
the budget because regardless of your
income level you should have a budget
and you should have a plan for your
money and so it's a great way to open up
the conversation where they get to speak
into it and you guys can plan that event
all right for that
i saw recently this guy had a
spreadsheet and him and his friends they
have very different incomes some are
broke some make hundreds of thousands of
dollars and they have a spreadsheet and
it shows what your budget is for these
trips who can make what and there's no
judgment there's none of this like well
you make this we're going on a bougie
trip they just go all right i'm broke
i'm not going on that trip yeah that's
it yeah and they have fun with it so i
thought that was a cool idea yeah
transparency and communication that's
good